attendre le bus en écoutant de la
musique
après le succès des opérations musique
en garde 2015 car jaune et le
département relance l'expérience avec un
spécial fête de la musique
quand
tombeur 4 rendez vous au programme à la
gare de saint benoît saint denis saint
paul ou encore saint pierre une scène
est ouverte pour permettre aux jeunes
artistes locaux de se faire connaître
je fais un peu de douche et durable fait
laden salle je suis d'islam du reggae
hélas aujourd'hui profité pour présenter
quelques extraits de mon nouvel album
par mon premier album
j'aurais aimé la scène et que ce soit
une gare ou une scène pour moi ça vole
chose en fait une initiative qui ravit
les artistes et qui est très bien
accueillie par les voyageurs comment
quelques personnes qui sont arrêtés pour
nous écouter chanter c'est cool ça ça
fait chaud au coeur
pour venir jusqu'à plaisir représenter
un peu notre quartier en fête
ben moi je viens d'arriver je vois que
de la musique c'est très bien ça va
attirer d'autres voyageurs et moi je
vais continuer à apprendre l'arabe à
lagord ok mais bus par ce ton est un peu
la nausée
c'est l'animation c'est pour détendre
l'atmosphère étant un peu lagacé de
voilà deux d'être mieux d'être mieux
d'être prudent voilà être vu dans la
journée dans l'après-midi écouter un peu
de musique pour détendre un peu les gens
qui songent à mon tour
tu trouves
l'objectif de cars jaunes et du
département les simples animer ces lieux
de passage emprunté par plus de 50 % des
usagers